[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes with me your host this week
Katie Bulls
coming up on the show
is Britain in for a big economic squeeze
the government's Autumn statement today
promised spending cuts and tax raises
but who will it hit the hardest our
politics team Kate Andrews Jameson is
for Hardman joined me to discuss
for the first time in the Ukraine Russia
War a missile hit NATO member Poland now
seen as a misfire from Ukraine how will
Poland react to this if you speak to
Ukrainian reporter
ilyaponomarenko and spectator journalist
Lisa hasseldine
the unrest in Iran intensified this week
as a number of protesters detained past
14 000. what began as a movement to ban
the hijab has turned into a wider revolt
against the Islamic Republic activists
and writers Joey joins me to discuss
what the future might look like
how deep does corruption stem inside the
Metropolitan Police is the odd bent
copper or is the problem more systemic
we'll be speaking to Tom Harper or for a
broken yard that falls the Metropolitan
Police which was reviewed in the
magazine this week and now across the
pond the announcement American pundits
have all been predicting
Donald Trump has declared he is standing
to try to be the presidential election
candidate for the Republican party in
2024.
but why was the announcement so rushed
to discuss I'm dreamed by Freddie gray
and Jacob halbron and finally as
Christmas approaches are Santa's grottos
becoming a thing of the past journalists
and author Lori Graham thinks so she
joins me on the show to discuss her own
efforts
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV then do subscribe to our
YouTube channel just click the Subscribe
button at the bottom of the video and
tap the Bell icon so you never miss an
episode
first up today brought the much
anticipated Autumn statement for the
cover piece this week Kate Andrews looks
at Britain's big squeeze who is going to
Bear the brunt of the government's new
fiscal plan she joins me now along with
our politics team James Forsyth and
Isabel Hardman
Kate in advance of the Autumn statement
you've had Jeremy Hunt using multiple
interviews to say it was going to be
very bad and he was going to be Scrooge
was it as bad as we expected
it's pretty bad it is also what we
expected after the Liz truss and
quasi-quarteng mini budget uh had so
many surprises in it which uh in
including shocking all of us shocked the
markets and sent the market spiraling
unsurprisingly they decided not to
really pull any rabbits out of hats so
we got what had been billed actually a
little bit less than what had been
briefed and considered in in the weeks
leading up to the Autumn statement
um but the the main headline is that the
chancellor is practicing a consolidation
of 55 billion pounds and this is coming
from about 25 billion pounds worth of
tax hikes and 30 billion pounds worth of
spending cuts leading up to 2027-28 the
biggest tax is that major stealth tax
which is a freeze on thresholds for
personal income for National Insurance
contributions and for inheritance tax
this is expected to drag over a million
people into the 40p tax rate or above
the threshold for the 45p tax rate has
also been lowered which is a direct
rebuke of the mini budget in September
Liz trust wanted to abolish it all
together Richard C Nick and Jeremy Hunt
have actually dragged more people into
that tax rate overall this Autumn
statement takes the tax board into a
post-war high and uh very worryingly
we're looking at the biggest fall in
living standards in post-war history
there is no doubt that the combination
of inflation and these tax hikes and
these spending cuts is going to cause a
lot of financial pain what the
government has succeeded in doing is
getting the government back on track
when it comes to its fiscal rules when
it comes to getting the public finances
back in order but of course the question
over the next couple of months and
indeed years is whether or not that
fiscal pain is going to be tolerated by
the public
is about what message was Jeremy Hunt
and Richard Cena ultimately trying to
convey when it came to the Autumn
statement
well in case we missed it Jeremy Hunt
made sure that he he told us by saying
he had two priorities so one was that
those who had more would contribute more
and the other was ensuring uh that there
would be growth and continued investment
in public services and as Kate has just
said that you know there was obviously
that very strong briefing before the
Autumn statement that this was going to
be really difficult but there was a lot
of emphasis within the statement on
public spending particularly with
regards education and the NHS in fact
one of Jeremy Hunt's only jokes I think
in the statement was where he talked
about suggestions made by the former
chair of Health and Social care select
committee who'd even written a book on
the topic he was also talking about
himself and for Workforce forecasting
for the NHS and he then also pointed out
that the spending increase that he was
announcing was something that Amanda
Pritchard chief executive of the Health
Service had would be sufficient to keep
the Health Service going so sort of
trying to ensure a kind of buy-in and
then on education he really used the
language that he used to use when he was
Health secretary in terms of talking
about the workforce in the teaching
profession he thanked the teachers for
the brilliant job they were doing and
said that spending on education was
going to go up as well I thought it was
significant there that he mentioned the
legacy of Michael Gove trying to remind
the conservatives of things that they
have to be proud of over the past decade
and a bit of their time in government so
overall it was a I wouldn't say it was
an upbeat statement but as we'd been
expecting it was a more forward-looking
and constructive statement than the the
sort of briefings of Doom beforehand had
suggested it was going to be
and James was also an attempt wasn't
there to almost
um
show some lag when it comes to labor or
Park tanks on their lawn when it comes
to two new Consultants advisory roles
yeah so Patricia Hewitt who was a health
secretary under the last Labor
government she will advise on these
integrated boards doing that do both
Health and Social care and Michael
Barber who founded Tony Blair's delivery
unit will advise on on skills and I
think you saw with this extra money for
the NHS there's extra money for schools
you know an attempt to to show that look
you know yes we're having to do some
unpleasant things but we are putting
more money into schools and hospitals I
think the big question is whether the
tourists can get back to their public
service reform agenda Victoria party
used to talk about delivering More For
Less in in recent years it has felt like
it's been less for more and I mean the
big question is whether they can make
this spending go further and whether
they can tackle some of these problems
because if you can't get better value
for money out of public services and get
some growth going in the economy then uh
then the tax burden is going to end up
going up a higher and that is going to
depress economic growth
and Isabel when it comes to the
Parliamentary party and if it's
interesting how Jeremy Hunt was
ultimately pointing very heavily to
Global factors though he did make one
remark about how when it came to the Liz
trust quasi-quartang area you could not
you know it was dangerous to borrow for
tax cuts just as it was for spending and
but do we have much of a sense of how
this is landing in terms of Tory MPS if
those on the right are going to wear it
well we obviously had the threat
yesterday at Prime Minister's questions
from Esther McVeigh that she wouldn't
support the tax measures in the Autumn
statement if hs2 went ahead which hunt
confirmed it would do today so perhaps
we'll get a rebellion from her but in
terms of a a wider Rebellion I think
there's there's still a a possibility
that might not happen so Simon Clark has
been tweeting about the need for supply
side reform he hadn't gone as far in his
threats as Esther McVeigh anyway but
there was certainly an attempt by hunt
in his speech to underline that these
were conservative measures this was the
sort of things that conservatives do
just not so much to attack the labor
party as chancellors tend to do but
actually to remind those on the benches
behind him that this is a conservative
government because one of the complaints
when Hunt's boss Rishi sunak was
Chancellor from people of a similar
persuasion to Esther McVeigh was that
there weren't many conservative policies
uh being unveiled that was partly as a
result of covid but the pressure to cut
taxes cut spending from the you know the
right of the conservative party it's
certainly added to the popularity of the
the Liz truss pitch during that first
leadership contest in the summer about
unfunded tax cuts
Kate finally I mean there's plenty for
MPS on the right to dislike about this
if you look for example at the new
changes to the windfall tax the plan to
bring in much more Revenue through that
metric and but in terms of how things
are going to feel over the next few
years
um ultimately you have the OVR saying
this is going to be you know a big fall
in living standards over the next two
years
um is it going to be very drastic is it
something where even atori MP is back at
now both Jeremy Hunt and Richardson are
going to be facing more requests for
funding in the coming months a cynic
might say that part of the design of
this Autumn statement was to make it the
worst it could possibly be because it
can only go up from here you know if
some of these measures do add a little
bit of growth to the obr's forecast then
perhaps sunak and Hunt can start rolling
some of these measures back even
introduce a tax cutter to the closer we
get to an election but I actually I
think maybe there's an element of that
but mostly I think it was very honest
statement
um that wake-up call that has been
coming that all of the money not just
that we spent in covid but all of the
money that we pledge for pensions and
Health Care long before covet hit
through successive governments labor and
Tori and Coalition meant that at some
point we were going to have to pay for
it and I think that this statement is is
sort of that that first real indicator
that that these costs are catching up
with us and that the era of cheap
borrowing is over at least for now and
if you can't borrow this money it's not
just that that the rich are going to pay
I mean the rich are certainly paying
more but everybody's going to be paying
for it too one of the really worrying
factors from the obr that we've dug into
is are the inflation figures and it
looks like the the average inflation
they're expecting for next year is still
going to be 7.5 percent roughly so well
above the bank's uh Target of two
percent so that combination of tax Rises
and inflation persisting
um is really going to make the next year
at least very difficult and you know I I
have some sympathy I really do as much
as I hate tax hikes as much as I don't
like
um brutal spending cuts over a short
period of time I think it makes them
less thoughtful you can have a lot of
sympathy for this government trying to
get to public finances back on track
given not just what happened during the
trust era but the global phenomenon of
rising interest rates and higher
borrowing costs and the rest of it I
think the difficulty however for student
that can hunt now is that in this Autumn
statement you still saw some very
serious giveaways they still haven't
touched the triple lock on state
pensions a quarter of which are going to
millionaire households there's still
more money for the NHS despite in his
own statement Jeremy Hunt basically
suggesting the Scandinavian systems in
the Singaporean systems are better for
providing health care and so whilst
they're willing to be very honest about
the state of the public finances we're
not having the honest conversation yet
about the actual public services that
are requiring these additional taxes
they disproportionately are going to
benefit the pensioners and uh you know
it's a core voting block for the Tories
no doubt but I think it's becoming
harder and harder to deny that the
decisions being made have a real
electoral slant and if you are under the
age of 40 certainly if you're not on the
property ladder yet
um there's very very little in this
Autumn statement for you it's it's just
bad news it's just bigger taxes more tax
hikes and and handing over more of your
income to the state
um and you know again I think there's a
really big question about how long you
can do that before it severely backfires
and Kate just on that final point you
made about the young I mean we've heard
from Richard Cena and Jeremy Hunt that
they want to say that in contrast I
think to The Not So Many budget by this
trust of this
um Autumn statement is about uh looking
after the most vulnerable that's been a
clear Focus the wealthiest are going to
have to pay the most but which group do
you think does come out worse when you
look at the measures is is it the is it
the Young
well we're still breaking it down but
the you know the marginal tax rate for
everybody is is going up I mean even if
you are a very low income earner if you
you know don't own your home if you're
not receiving certain kinds of benefits
if you're not receiving the pension yet
um again there's there's very little in
here for you
um so if you are in one of those
protected groups that's classified as
vulnerable
um you know I wouldn't say that it's the
best budget for you because if you are
genuinely vulnerable in one of those
groups you know times are still going to
be really tough I think the difficulty
is what is still being classified as
vulnerable includes millionaire
pensioners and we know from see you next
time as Chancellor that behind closed
doors going back to 2020 he was actually
pushing to reform the triple lock on
state pensions he thought that was the
time to tackle the the unfairness of
that policy and and and the extent
um to which it was benefiting people who
actually didn't always need it
um and it's clear that he's not ready to
do that yet now in my piece for the
magazine this week uh you know I spoke
to a government Insider he made the
legitimate point and I'm paraphrasing
here that you can't get the public
finances back on track and make those
difficult decisions and reform all the
public services at the same time that's
just politically not feasible and you
know I really do take that point but the
problem is that this government is
operating not on borrowed time but on
limited time the next election could be
18 months away and and we know that CNAC
is Keen to reform but whether or not he
can when he's actually in charge I think
will be a big part of what ends up
defining his legacy
thank you Kate thank you Isabel and
thank you James
odd leaders met in Bali at the G20 and
missile was fired into polish land
killing two people initial reports
accudes the Russians sparking an
emergency NATO meeting but it's now
likely it was a Ukrainian missile
after the success in cursing is this a
problem for Ukraine and polish diplomacy
I'm joined by Elia panamerenko and
spectator contributor Lisa hasseldine
Elia what do we know at this point
so what happened yesterday
um was was probably big death the mother
of the Russian missile attack against
Ukraine because he last night they fired
close to 100 missiles against
um Ukrainian critical infrastructure all
across the country in Kiev nipro ASAP
as well
and judging from the latest things that
we have learned from the scene and the
pictures of the debris one of the
Ukrainian
um air defense missiles that was trying
to intercept the Russian missiles in
common uh if two of them must probably
fell down on the polished Soul we do not
know if they successfully intercepted
the the missiles or if they fail to do
so but anyways they debris the pictures
of the debris from the scene suggest
that that was the Ukrainian air defense
missile from the s-300 missile system
so that's that was
um that was was probably what was
happening Lisa since ultimately those
reports first emerged we've had a
situation where Western leaders have
been very clear Keen to urge caution uh
so ultimately saying the conflict Russia
is to blame but when it comes to these
missiles that's not jump to conclusions
actually as we just heard um they could
have been Ukrainian and therefore
ultimately this idea that we should
respond because of NATO whole breath but
has it gone down in Russia when reports
first emerged so the response in Russia
has actually been quite interesting so
when the news first broke uh I think
there was some confusion amongst of
Kremlin spokespeople and the state media
around how to respond so you heard some
people like Margarita simonyan who is
quite a prominent sort of propagandist
basically come out gloating sort of
saying you know Poland how do you like
that you know that sort of message then
it began to emerge that the Russian
State media was taking a different tax
so a couple of hours after the news
broke the Russian Ministry of Defense
came out with a statement denying
responsibility for this missile and that
I think really set the tone for then how
um the rest of the propaganda machine
the rest of State
media began to sort of talk about it so
suddenly the line was well no it's not
us we are not responsible no way and any
sort of leader because obviously there
were lots of world leaders gathered at
the G20 who were sort of giving comment
on this
um any leader who sort of gave any
comments saying either hold fire or no
no actually wants more details began to
emerge we don't think this is
necessarily Russia
um you saw a lot of reports emerging in
the pressing oh actually you know what
yeah look see they are saying that this
is that this that we're not responsible
we should listen to them which I think
is again is quite interesting because
it's not often that you see them
necessarily agreeing with what western
leaders have been saying
um but then obviously there's the
conspiracy theory angle as well so the
Russian Ministry of Defense in their
statements denied sending any missiles
to that part of Ukraine that's close to
that part of the Polish border
and you then began to see particularly
once the Russian military blogger
Community
these theories that have been bandied
around saying well you know the ministry
of Defense has denied has said they
haven't sent any missiles so it couldn't
even possibly be Ukrainian air defense
systems that were up in the air because
there were no missiles for them to knock
out of the sky so what options that
leave is there a provocation by Poland
itself which is also part of
um the ministry of defense's denial so
yeah it's been a mixed picture but
ultimately one where the Russian press
has fallen behind the state to deny any
involvement at all Elia what
significance do you think this has in
terms of The Wider conflict because of
course until now it's been a a contained
conflict and even if this is a misfire
do you think the fact that missiles have
now led to polish fatalities is going to
lead to a change in mood when it comes
to who should be doing what
I don't think that there's going to be
some sort of a you know God breaking
events or significant shift of mode
towards the the war you know because you
know the public opinion has been
established regarding the
um the Ukraine the Ukrainian situation
and then in the Russian war in general
especially in Poland Poland remains one
of the most fierce supporters in
Advocates of Ukraine obviously out of
obvious reasons the thing is that yes
it's a very confusing very strange
incident
um even from the technical points of
view uh it's
so it's absolutely possible it's not an
unusual situation when it comes to you
know to Warfare it happens all the time
but uh this time the degrees ended up
being on the Polish soil which is
technically it's very surprising still
because the uh the Ukrainian missiles
are air defense missiles they have the
mechanism of self-destruct if they fail
to accept the uh the incoming missile so
most likely they will be simply enjoyed
in the air and then fell down without
bringing any harm but nonetheless most
likely something something else happens
uh in general I don't think that's uh
it's going to be a
huge impact on this especially given the
fact that obviously it's not it was not
an intentional Russian attack uh on the
uh on the Polish soil it was definitely
not the Ukrainian you know conspiracy to
um you know bring Poland and NATO into
World War III against Russia it was
something that happens all the time
during this war since day one and will
be happening until the the final day of
the final hour of this war which is the
tragic lots of tragic things are
happening on the margins of warfare
and this I know you've been looking at
Russian media and some of your coverage
for the spectator
um do we have any sense yet where almost
the mood of the nation is when it comes
to um Putin's efforts because we're
obviously seeing lots of reports which
are you know ultimately the fact the
ukrainians are you know making some
games and making some wins is that
feeding back in terms of the public mood
in Moscow yeah so I think there are
definitely beginning to be some shifts I
think the important thing to say from
the outset is that in terms of any
official way of gauging the mood in
Russia it's very difficult to do because
um it's impossible to basically conduct
any sort of trustworthy polling um
gauging sort of a real sense of how
Russian people are thinking or what
they're saying can be very difficult
obviously again because of censorship
laws but yes I think there is
um there have been reports of Russian
mothers traveling to the Ukrainian front
to try and persuade their sons to
dessert to come home
um Putin's
failed partial mob mobilization efforts
as well have really
um had a knock-on effect domestically
people
um
there are petitions that are cropping up
for um to the government to try and sort
of repeal some of those mobilization
orders so yeah I think there is a sense
that
perhaps Direct by drip sentiment in
Russia is changing about the war and
Elia now that Ukraine has taken back
Kirsten uh clearly there's been Harold
as a big victory we have a tough winter
ahead are we any clearer on what the end
game might be to all this
you know it's very very hard to make any
clear predictions
um especially given the fact that the
war has so many surprises it's so
obscure and the focal war is so thick so
maybe we should be talking not about you
know predictions but about possibilities
of what happened
um by analyzing the pace of the war and
how it's how it's going and by talking
about Trends I think we can
realistically optimistically talk about
the possible end of the war probably by
next summer time
probably why because
um obviously we decrease on Victory and
other victories on the front line uh
Ukrainian pictures they have
demonstrated they diverge the base of
the war has been reversed
ultimately now it's Ukraine that's
prevailing slowly painfully but it's
prevailing The Verge has been reversed
and uh
the winter time is coming of course and
the nature of winter Warfare will slow
down the hostilities the it's going to
be more about
um Logistics the war of logistics the
war between two sides in terms of
whoever is best prepared for winter
Warfare uh Logistics and supplies and
also the war in civilian beer the
constant war between Russian missiles
and Ukrainian workers I'm trying to you
know fix the energy system and keep the
country kind of effluenced then the
Sprint time comes most probably this
Springtime campaign would be
um crucial would be defining and
probably
well maybe we'll get something that
could be treated as the Ukrainian
Victory
um
the most important thing
um in here is that Russia needs to be
denied of its ability to go on to
allegian this war in offense in terms of
offense also defense when it's not
capable of doing that the war is over
and it's time for negotiations and some
negotiated end to this war Alisa what
about Russia's position when it comes to
Global Affairs because we just had the
G20 and Putin did not attend but how did
lavrov go lavrov got the cold shoulder
um so he went to Putin's uh
representative Putin it was announced
last week wasn't going to go and pretty
much from the off
tensions were pretty high I think it's
fair to say at the summit
um sort of even before uh the main
Summit kicked off uh us and China had
um a sort of bilateral where she had
again sort of uh condemned Russia's
threats to escalate in a nuclear fashion
and then of course during the summer
itself pretty much any world leader that
got the chance to speak took it as an
opportunity to have a pop at Russia
including Rishi sunak who with lavrov in
the room said
um that basically Russia needed to end
this Bob end this barbaric war and get
out of Ukraine he also gave him an angry
stare right yeah exactly yeah if not
were quick to release the photo of yeah
exactly if it looks could kill
um and then of course uh yeah even
countries such as India and China as I
mentioned who have always up until now
pretty much I guess supported Russia or
at least not
actively condemned its war in Ukraine
even they're clearly beginning to feel
uncomfortable about the current
situation
um Modi and she also spoke out on things
like the fact that Putin has been
um controlling grain exports in the
Ukraine and weaponizing food stocks as a
result of that Modi also um basically
said that the G20 was a good opportunity
to try and make progress in terms of
reaching some sort of or beginning
rather some sort of negotiations on the
war so yeah
um Russia did not have a good G20 put it
that way thank you Evia Thank you Lisa
Iran's protests intensified this week
sparked initially by the death of Mazda
amini a young woman who was detained for
wearing a headdress inappropriately
the last 58 days of demonstration of
Stephen won 14 000 arrests and 320
people have died why was this week
crucial to the movement
I'm joined by Mansura Joey a writer and
Iranian women's rights activist
thank you for coming on spectator TV
this week
the situation Iran has heightened
further when it comes to the protests
can you update us on what's been going
on
um actually the women life freedom is a
movement is ongoing movement in this
week it's very intensive because this
week is the anniversary week of protests
called bloody November really bloody
November in 20 to 2019. after the
government announced that the gasoline
price
is rising in this protest
spreading more than 100 cities the
protests quickly
extending into opposition to uh Balia
and you know take not only about the
gasoline price but also about the lack
of Justice lack of freedom and the
opposition against the dictatorship
about one thousand five five hundred
people uh were killed among Iranian
protesters nowadays the ongoing movement
women life freedom is linked with this
anniversary when it comes to those
protests over the hijab um you mentioned
of the the women's rights protests we've
had a situation this week where 272
lawmakers of 290 have ultimately voted
to implement the death penalty for
crimes against the state
um do we have any sense of how that is
um being met with the public in terms of
support or lack of
as supporters we as supporters of the
women life Freedom Movement and are in
Iran and around the world uh call for
desolation
the Revolutionary court and Shane troyal
and demand that the death penalty
centers could be should be stopped we
asked all of the community International
institution human rights institution to
support us
and simultaneously a public apple is
turning among the social media and up to
now more than 100
000 signatures has been ratified do you
think the threat of execution for uh you
know taking part in these protests will
work as the Iranian regime wants it to
to reduce the number willing to go out
there and protest
I can say that
the the measure of the pressure the
measure of the Injustice the measure of
the lack of dignity of life and Humanity
in Iran and the measure of women's
pressure women's discrimination
is
is more than is more than the the sense
of feel the sense of you know and people
want to be brave
bravely they they they they they took a
street however they know that yes of
course the execution could be uh could
be a very very
very horrible risk that's why we we want
we insist
to to to call and to ask the the
humanity human rights institution to
help us to support the protester and to
to do something to stop this shame trial
and just finally when it comes to these
protests how much of this is about the
hijab and how much is this about
um a more General fight for freedom and
rights
uh the the start points actually the
start point was
a hijab but now it is a general
coalitional and inclusive uh movement
and you can see a lot of social Guru
ethnic group religion group labors
students a lot of people join this for
women life freedom and Freedom the third
part of the slogan Freedom it's a
freedom it's a general freedom for women
and men
thank you for joining spectator TV today
we've heard a lot about bent coppers
both fictional on TV and in real life
following high profile cases like
Stephen Lawrence but how deep does
corruption feed into the Metropolitan
Police and at what point does it start
creeping in
journalist Tom Harper has just released
the book broken yard before the
Metropolitan Police which was reviewed
in this week's magazine he joins me now
Tom thanks for joining spectator TV this
week
um your new book is reviewed in the
literary section of the magazine about
the Metropolitan Police when did it
become corrupt well I think the
Metropolitan Police has always been
corrupt as as most major institutions
have been
I think what's changed in the last few
decades is
the public have become more aware of of
some of the more serious issues for
various reasons
um coupled with that there's been a
worrying decline in standards and
supervision and training which has also
contributed to things getting pretty bad
and I suppose when it comes to this
creeping corruption I mean we see lots
of things today recent reports about the
behavior of map offices themselves but
are there a few moments that you think
uh the point where it particularly worse
and we're changing points in this
well I started journalism just around
the time of Jean Charles Jimenez as his
death in 2006 and I started covering the
met at that point and that was a big
moment for me I was very shocked at what
happened around that you probably
remember
um an innocent Brazilian man was shot
dead by counterterrorism police on the
Streets of London after he was mistaken
for a terror suspect and
um in the aftermath of the event the the
Metropolitan Police put out lots of
information in an apparent attempt to
muddy his name and sort of justify what
they'd done which
um I just couldn't really believe and so
that that was a big moment for me and
um also speaks to what I think is
probably the major problem with the Met
is is defensiveness and its uh
willingness to be dishonest about
certain things which
um although not the most serious things
in the grand scheme of things obviously
there's much more serious corruption
organized crime and so on uh within the
met but it's that sense of dishonesty
and lack of accountability and
unwillingness to admit mistakes which I
think has ultimately eroded the trust
between the met and the public and the
politicians that oversee it to such a
great extent
and what was it that ultimately
triggered you to write this book was it
incidence uh like this or was there a
moment when you thought this is
something which deserves you know uh we
as Janice obviously write um plenty of
articles but deserves uh dedicated time
to it
yeah I mean well you probably know Katie
we as journalists we cover all these
different stories
um and write you know 700 words a
thousand words or whatever and move on
to the next story and I just felt that
there was a narrative there within what
I'd covered over the last 15 16 years
covering the police where
um
things were happening and we covered
them and then we moved on and the public
moved on the media moved on and actually
I thought if someone tried to pull it
all together and try and make some sense
of it in one narrative that might be
interesting to read it and I hope it is
now they have recently been
um efforts to ultimately you know crack
a Crackdown on this so the
anti-corruption unit marked Riley the
new um commissioner has been speaking
about
um do you think this is going to make a
big difference from what you've uh you
know tracked in terms of
um what's been happening over the past
few decades
I think Mark Rowley is saying the right
things and as I've said previously we
all I wish him well I think we should
all wish him well I think we all as a
society need the police to be a far
stronger uh and far better functioning
uh institution than it is now so I wish
him well I do have serious reservations
about his ability to deliver some of
what he's saying the police are still
woefully underfunded in my view there's
been a terrifying decline in standards
and
training over many years which means
in my opinion a lot of the police don't
really know what they're doing
um the recent events over the just stop
oil protests I've said recently that it
just they're standing around not wanting
to enforce the law
um and they don't seem to know the laws
that they're able to enforce these
protesters sort of shutting down the M25
and so on they're committing criminal
offenses whether whatever you think
about climate change the police could
have arrested them and moved them off
the roads quite easily for obstruction
of the highway and criminal damage but
they don't and I think
until more officers are feel empowered
and also
are properly briefed on what they're
able to do and what their powers are I
think they will struggle
what do you think it's down to I mean
obviously you're talking about funding
it comes to you know the just stop oil
protest for example do you think there's
a worry that uh if they do something the
leadership may not have their back there
is a complaint and so forth
yes I think
um some of the people I interviewed for
the book spell this out very clearly
there's a um
very troubling loss of confidence
overall amongst police officers and
serious concerns that they will fulfoul
of the media or their senior officers or
Regulators or politicians and it's
almost like they don't really want to
make any mistakes so they won't do
anything at all obviously that's a
sweeping generalization but that there's
that General sense that
um it's probably better to just stay in
in the police station
um you know looking at social media
rather than getting out onto the streets
and actually affecting change and
cutting crime
so when it comes to what can be done I
think of course first to ultimately
bring an end or at least reduce the
level of corruption in the map but also
in terms of some of the behaviors we're
talking about what do you think the
steps are one thing you talk about is
idea of returning to patch reporting
which is which the reviewer questions
yes my understanding of what he said is
um
I was calling for a return to uh
increased use of criminal informants
which is uh sources within the
underworld that the police officers
um recruit and obtain information from
um and that was a long-standing practice
over decades
and has fallen away to a great extent
and I the reviewers criticized me for
calling for that saying I didn't
understand that a lot of the corruption
in the police came from that very
relationship between informal and
Handler
I felt that I tried it's a complicated
situation I did feel that I said that it
that is absolutely where a lot of
corruption came from
um and it's not an easy path to take but
I do feel uh to some extent
um the complete lack of informance in
the med it could be seen as sort of
throwing the baby out of the bath water
you know that they're so terrified of
um informants and that
um that handling process where things
can go horribly wrong that they're just
not not dealing with them anymore and
um we do have a lot of technical
expertise in our ability to intercept
Communications and so on and obtain
intelligence the human informants are an
absolutely vital source of intelligence
to the police and the security services
and to not really have many if at all
anymore I think is a big mistake
and just finally PF King in his review
your book talks about a particular type
of British corruption we can see in
various ways one being the number of
attorneys in public life but I wonder
when it comes to the Met police
corruption do you think that it is
possible to you know root out I mean
nearly all corruption or is that
actually an impossible task of what is
the goal here
no I don't think it's possible to root
out corruption completely the Met is an
organization of something like 32 000
police officers and several thousand
back office staff so you're always going
to get
um individuals who are compromised or
individuals who have low ethical
standards but I think so much more could
be done
um I think it's a a long way back to
something approaching normality I think
um
to some extent the police have stuck
their heads in the Sands collectively
for about 20 years on corruption and not
done a lot to try and tackle it since
about the early naughties late 90s so
um to turn that oil tank around will
take some time
and
in terms of the public if they lose
confidence in the mat and do you think
that makes this task even harder because
you have to go Fairless to win it back
absolutely public confidence is vital
for all sorts of reasons
um and I think the Public's confidence
in the met and policing more generally
has been severely shaken not least
amongst women which is obviously more
than 50 cents of the population with the
terrible events around the Sarah everard
murder
um alone so ostracizing large sways of
the population
um but yeah I think I think that they've
they desperately need the support of the
public
um and you know despite everything I
hope the public do continue to try and
support them because
um it's a symbiotic relationship really
uh Law and Order and the police and the
public and we've all got to work
together to try and um get get this
country in a better place thank you Tom
thanks for joining us today
after months of speculation Donald Trump
confirmed that he does plan to seek the
Republican nomination for 2024.
however what are his chances and has he
rushed the announcement to discuss I've
now driven by Freddie gray and Jacob
halbron
so Freddie Donald Trump is back he's
trying to make Trump 2024 happen are you
surprised not really no I think there
was a little bit of Doubt uh was cast
about I spoke to some people who who
speak to Trump as people love to say uh
on a regular basis and uh the last week
and I was I was struck that they sounded
a little bit more dubious a bit more
doubtful I think there was a little bit
of uh disappointment disgruntlement with
the midterms and it's feeling that maybe
project Trump isn't going so well but if
you look at it sort of if you pan out a
bit and look at it more broadly Trump
has never really stopped campaigning uh
for the last 10 years really uh he has
always done these rallies when he was in
the white house he did the rallies
pretty much as soon as he was out of the
White House he was still doing the
rallies the fundraising has always
carried on it's a business the Trump
campaign is a business
um and the incentives for it to carry on
are very strong so I think it's no real
great surprise
um that he announced Jacob do you think
that the timing of this is related to
the midterms because lots of people were
questioning uh Trump's electoral appeal
you look at some of those results from
the candidates who is so closely
Affiliated to Donald Trump as it meant
he's rushed forward this announcement to
keep momentum going he has indeed the
timing was unpropicious just as his
speech fell flat at Mar-A-Lago the
difficulty he faced was he had
anticipated as many Americans had that
there would be a red wave which turned
into barely even a ripple the idea was
originally that he would emerge as the
triumphant Victor from the midterms that
the candidates that he had endorsed
particularly for the Senate would win
instead
almost all of them crashed and burned
including in Pennsylvania where Mehmet
Oz the doctor that he endorsed lost to
John fetterman this these defeats were
ignominious for Trump and have triggered
in incipient Civil War in the GOP over
him he felt he had no choice but to try
and position himself in front of it by
declaring his candidate he seen now the
difficulty for him I think is that in
declaring prematurely
the the sizzle is gone he's going to be
campaigning now for two years Ron
DeSantis in Florida will wait and let
Trump
essentially burn out over the next
couple months
is chances um Freddy is he now
ultimately seen as the most likely pick
or do you think that Donald Trump still
has a decent shot of this I think the
bookmakers are now making him the
favorite I think that might be a little
premature Jacob makes a very good point
that Trump is now going to be
campaigning for too long and people do
seem to be a bit exhausted with him even
some of his old fans are getting tired
of him
um but DeSantis is not quite the perfect
candidate that um everybody thinks he is
nobody is the perfect candidate and he
is very much an old establishment
Republican at heart and Trump will
attack him as a rhino that means a
republican name only and those attacks
might be unfair but they will certainly
stick and I think people will see that
that DeSantis embraced Trump trumpism
that is very famous embarrassing
campaign advert he did where he sort of
showed himself reading Trump's book The
Art of the deal to his baby he was just
sucking up to Trump in a big way and
people see that DeSantis Embrace
trumpism because it was of the smart
clever thing to do
they might think
uh he's not really a True Believer
um that said the status has been a very
clever operator as governor and we
shouldn't underestimate him can I
interject yeah I have to correct Freddie
on this okay
let's stand ready to be corrected the to
call DeSantis a rhino I don't think is
fair I didn't say he was I said Trump
will call him I think it will be very
difficult for Trump to do that there's
one big reason he is going to campaign
to the right of Donald Trump on the
covid issue he's going to say that
Donald Trump was responsible for the
lockdowns that Donald Trump stood by
Anthony fauci he will Pummel him on that
and he will say that in Florida by
contrast we did not order lockdowns we
kept the schools open and we did not
kowtow to the federal government headed
by both Donald Trump and then Joe Biden
so I think DeSantis will put Trump in a
difficult position I'm not saying that
he necessarily wins the nomination he
does have some weaknesses that I think
will be very hard for Trump to pick to
Tar him as some kind of a clause it
liberal Republican I take that point and
I think Trump is weak to his right on
covid stuff uh notably the vaccines
vaccine mandates Candice Owens who was
the sort of trump sycophant for a long
time uh has come out recently and sort
of declared that she felt he was she he
treated her unfairly because he she
dared questioned him about the vaccine
mandates uh and so I do think Trump is
weak to his right and there's a little
bit of disenchantment uh on the right
however
he is the Godfather he is trumpism with
it without Trump you don't have trumpism
so a lot of these essays being written
at the moment about the future of the
writers trumpism without Trump that's
nonsense to a certain extent because
it's a non-sequitur uh he is the father
of the movement
Gene what about Donald Trump's legal
issues and what impact is this going to
have on his campaign well his obvious
attempt is to defuse the legal issues by
depicting himself as a victim of a rogue
justice department that is out to
demolish the Republican front-runner for
the presidential nomination
I don't think that that tactic will work
and I think he is going to be facing
legal liability it will however
intensify his bond with the Republican
base I think it will cause him more
difficulties with mainstream Republicans
because it won't just it's likely to be
more than one indictment but we'll see
the justice department has not moved
ahead yet and would need to have an
iron-clad case on the on the documents
that he speared it away to Mar-A-Lago
and Merrick Garland the attorney general
has been exceedingly cautious in making
any public statements about Trump so
right now we're in a state of suspended
animation there is this interesting
Dynamic though isn't that Jacob
um the Department of Justice and the
Democrats behind it they do want to
persecute Trump uh for the reason that
they want Trump to run so they it helps
them if they can create this conspiracy
theory if they can make the conspiracy
theory true that they are out to
persecute Trump because they think their
best ticket for winning is for Trump to
still be around well I personally do not
think that the justice department is out
to persecute Trump in fact if you listen
to the Democratic base they're howling
that Merrick Garland is a sniveling
coward who doesn't have the cojones to
go after Trump I think it's it's all
overdone
um I Biden has has kept himself out of
this this were the Trump Administration
yes I'm sure Trump would be paying for
his adversary's heads in fact we know
that Trump tried to sick the IRS on his
opponents according to his former Chief
of Staff John Kelly so I think I think
you think the Mar-A-Lago raid is is
purely in the interests of justice and
preserving I mean they presidential the
question isn't why they went into
mar-a-laga but why they waited so long
they gave the guy every opportunity in
the world to cough these up the man is
pathological whether he did different
reasons of ego or because he wanted to
sell the documents I don't know but the
whole thing is utterly bizarre and
consonant with Trump's presidency which
was let's face it a debacle and and just
finally and we're looking at those
midterms ultimately the Democrats had a
better than expected performance so what
does that mean for Joe Biden are the
Democrats has stuck with him when it
comes to the next election well Joe
Budden reportedly has a spring in his
step this week and is in excellent
Spirits because he feels that he's been
Vindicated somewhat by these results I
think the Democrats should probably not
be quite so uh dreamy about what's going
to happen it looks like America is about
to enter a double dip recession
um the broader outlook for the next two
years does not look good
um and Joe Biden's performance is
generally seen as bad as job approval
ratings are low the right track wrong
track
um meter and American vast majority of
Americans think their country is on the
wrong track
um I think they could feel some pain in
2024 particularly if they think that
project Biden is working more than it
actually is I couldn't disagree more
okay excellent let's go I now know your
shock but I've been a uh a Biden uh
bullish on Biden since beginning I think
he is he is not a burden on the party
but he is the only one only Democrat
that can defeat Trump again he will run
again and he will win in 2024. can he
defeat DeSantis that would be a rougher
road but the Republican program is the
midterm show is not that popular so I
think Biden would have a strong chance
yes
thank you Jacob thank you Freddie
finally it may be mid-november but
Christmas preparations are well underway
as children start writing their wish
list will they still want to meet Santa
in his Grotto and should they
journalist and author Laurie Graham
writes about this in the magazine she
joins me now
Lori thanks for coming on spectator TV
this week now you've been working
recently on Santa's Grotto
tell me what does the centers Grotto in
the year of 2022 involve well it's a bit
sad really sort of uphill work so we
decorated our Grotto with empty
cardboard boxes wrapped in Christmas
paper basically yeah it gave it it was
it's early November so
um and um what I wasn't sure was exactly
what Santa would be allowed to do
because you know
strange men young children these days
and also were the children you know if
children were brought and their parents
were going to have to pay
for an audience with with Santa
whether children actually want that
these days I mean
Santa starts appearing
around about the end of August now
doesn't he
and also they have all these other
figures in there in their lives so that
Santa doesn't have any kind of magic I
imagine
do you think then in a world where
there's so much screen time or you know
access to the web video games and so
forth Santa's lost some of his law he
must have done he must have done and I
tell you something I saw actually just
yesterday
it was an advent calendar and it's in
the shape of Father Christmas
and behind each of the little 24 doors
there's a tiny plastic figure of a
superhero
oh
Santa has just become a kind of vehicle
for the stuff the kids really want
when it comes to festive figures however
in your piece you do write the elves are
back in Vogue was behind that is it
because you mentioned elf on a shelf yes
Richie sunac I think has spoken about
the current prime minister does he have
one yeah he has had one that he um yeah
he has spoken is used for his his
daughters are big fans of it or at least
when they're a bit younger and then you
also have Elf obviously the classic
Christmas film which never seems to go
away I've just come back for a flight
when it was suggested as one of the
films I should watch despite it being
November yes yes elf elf in the movies
that's that's rather nice figure I
thought I must say my grandchildren do
not object to the Elf on the Shelf even
though you know they're old enough now
to know exactly what's going on but I
thought it was a bit sinister
you know he's he's like a knock he's
noticing if you're being naughty and
reputedly Reporting back to Santa
probably nice is it so what is going to
be in The Grotto to entice the children
the man himself
um in fact in fact our Grotto has
happened since I since I wrote the piece
of a spectator and I must say he was a
wonderful a very very credible
um Santa Claus in stature you know and
um and his beard was genuine you know it
wasn't it was
it wasn't a strap-on bit of cotton wool
um
but you know I mean he didn't have a lot
of takers
business was slow
and um so from time to time he walked
around
and said yo ho ho or ho ho ho or
something like that uh I think it's a
sort of it's kind of a Dying profession
it's a bit sad I'm really really hoping
that lots of people are going to write
in and say oh Laurie Graham's got this
completely wrong and
so you had a Santa who had lots of time
for rest and children who were they more
interested in other Christmas activities
what do you think from grandchildren
also the children at your event is now
the most exciting thing about about
Christmas for for a young child is it
presents yeah it's stuff it's stuff it's
knowing what they want and they do know
and and knowing where you can get it so
you know there's no excuse
um for for the stuff on their list for
not appearing
um so yeah they've become very savvy
consumers really
um so if Santa's grottos are going out
of Vogue at least for now
barring a huge intervention from
spectator readers and what do you think
could be done to either reverse the
trend or bring in something new which is
probably a less present orientated yeah
well I mean I suppose they'd love to
meet Shrek or something in it so if you
want an experience I don't know you know
maybe it's not really for children
anyway maybe it's
it's for the grown-ups I mean personally
I can I
have been to a grotto once as a child
and I can remember my mother's high
expectations of
on my behalf and I was actually
terrified
and so
I was a disappointment to my mother or
it was a disappointing thing for her but
I think maybe maybe we just do it for
ourselves taking my grandchildren mostly
too old now but I've got the final batch
of younger ones coming through
I can't imagine myself taking them
to meet Santa but I suppose they might
like to meet
um Spider-Man or
and you might have not had a great
experience back in your youth obviously
still very youthful when you went to
Santos Grotto but did you learn if
perhaps this is more for the parents the
grown-ups the adults did you enjoy your
Grotto finally
no not really no I can't say I mean I do
think to sort of go back to what you
just asked me that you know the figure
of Saint Nicholas it's a it's a lovely
story and you know he was a real person
and maybe we just need to I think
December 6th this is is his feast day
you know he was a lovely old Bishop who
went around leaving Secret
you know a bit of money for people who
needed it and so on so I I would hate to
lose for us to lose that
maybe that's what we need to lean on a
bit more now
thank you Laurie
that's it for this week
once again don't forget to subscribe to
the spectator's YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode that's
everything for this week thanks again
for watching and do join us again next
week
foreign
[Music]